[Music]
in organized crime news organized not
disorganized crime no no no only way to
do it what would that be street gangs
that aren't sophisticated
yeah this is truly free Kings are
organized yeah submitted by big Johnson
mmm we just looked up a whole bunch
everyday we just made weird we're in the
classic video just penis episode world
Johnson doubt yeah what's been sent by a
dolphin
I'm way desensitized I don't want no
dicks in my life anymore armed robbers
made off with a huge cash haul in a
plane heist a plane eyes yes we recently
this is sick I thought this [ __ ] doesn't
happen anymore baby this is like [ __ ]
DB cooper [ __ ] it would be a DB cooper
DB Cooper's a guy who he held an airline
hostage in like the 70s or some [ __ ] and
you through the luggage down through the
luggage down they never found him yeah
I'm parachuted out yep yeah why was
there money on a plane yeah he was
holding it ransom and then he had them
land and then he had them load the cash
and then he had them give him a
parachute and then he used the parachute
and landed and they never found him but
they found like a lot of loose cash
around they keep finding lose cash but
they never found him or the main cash
it's a great story deeper that reminds
me of that new movie on Netflix with Ben
Affleck they went to go rob something
and they're leaving cash everywhere they
went trying to get back home I don't
wanna do the spoiler Hebei Nia sounds
like a country that's run by the mom
well this was pulled off by very very
organized people when I think of inside
John I think of Eastern Europe I think
that there is a lot of gangsters like
organized heist people like Russia is
yeah like like Russia's bad guys go to
Eastern Europe to do crime Yakuza type
[ __ ] yeah but like GTA level [ __ ] yeah
so they're saying that it was about 2.8
million dollars oh that's a heist bro
yeah and so they're saying like well why
was all this money there and they
that money regularly passes through this
international airport because Albania's
central bank does not accept deposits of
hard currency from foreign banks
operating in the country so they have to
deposit it directly into the central
bank so this money was leaving the
country mmm but the point is that they
got away with it and this isn't the
first time that there was an armed
robber at the armed robbery at the
airport back in 2016 three masked
robbers entered the terminal and stole
up to three point 38 million dollars I
was destined to be transported abroad so
yeah like armored truck on a new level
one of the armed robbers died in this
one is that US money I told you in US
money oh okay yeah that was you million
how the guide died oh he was shot my
nice friends they're like we want a
bigger tank they're just saying
so you must have been they drive into
the runway and then they they used a
fire services entrance stole the
shipment of money that was destined for
Vienna and the police ended up chasing
them and then that's when one of the
gunman was shot to death she was found
to be armed with an assault weapon a
grenade and a magazine and bullet you
don't play man see that's what I feel so
lucky to be in America sometimes because
like you can't I mean we get jacked and
stuff here but that's some crazy level
[ __ ] yeah so police arrested four of the
attackers and questioned 40 others
following the info yeah white people
with it and they're saying that this
this was from one of the most dangerous
gangs in the country wait was it were
there people on the airplane to like
like passengers so Dave they have people
on the airplane but they also have like
a safe with all the money I don't do
this commercial passenger
so they're saying so witnesses said that
they were dressed in military uniforms
and then they approach the airport staff
that were working by the plane and when
the engines were already running they
ordered them to the ground they took the
cargo of cash that had been loaded into
the hole oh [ __ ] there's man it's like
an armored car that comes and delivers
it and then they put it in the cargo
oh that's crazy how did they transport
it out of there they probably had like a
getaway car or something they didn't
though they got caught for yeah they got
away or killed one all the wrestling god
yeah it was a big team yep so then that
flight was able to depart for Vienna two
hours of 40 minutes behind schedule my
um so I have a friend she was an
assistant in Beijing - like the owner of
silicon and laugh and they say it's like
imagine like the CEO of Best Buy right
so it's like electronic store so she was
his personal assistant and she would say
like this guy roles with three armed
security cars full of like full staffed
security guards that are armed like
front seat back I mean the front and
insel he's cars in the middle and if you
kill they'll ride with him and then
dough-like caravan anywhere they go they
have a separate entrance into the tower
that they're in just for the CEO so I'm
like can you imagine living in a country
where you have to be like that I guess
like Trump has that here but I don't
think our CEOs do that like there's a
picture of Bill Gates in ordering
burgers at a restaurant in line and [ __ ]
yeah but dude he has yes security he
wasn't of a normal life but they're
probably like in the back like hiding
like ninja service but they're not like
our rich people are rich CEOs and I'll
just carry cash that streets more like -
it would be a kidnapping course it's all
electronic like break into their
electronic accounts but that's why I
worry about the tower beater and the guy
who did aetherium because he's like one
of the most known
Multi multi millionaires and it's like
dude he just walks around and [ __ ]
that's true they could know they
couldn't hack him because crypt is so
hard it's so much harder to hack no but
they get put a gun to his head and like
you'll give us your [ __ ] yeah but like
what if he doesn't
please kill yeah I mean yeah it's pretty
crazy
yeah and then all of it the whole Syrian
project like get exact you set back and
[ __ ] we don't want that no I mean I feel
like I would just die because I would
feel like they're probably gonna kill me
anyway
oh nice yeah I'm like like I don't know
I think I think a worst-case scenario
like so worst-case scenario I give you
everything you destroy everything and
you kill me [ __ ] you you I'm not gonna
give you I start bargaining I'll be like
how about I suck at his dicks all your
dicks
come on do y'all ever had a guy gangbang
before I never have I feel good you know
kill you oh [ __ ] that's even worse
that's my opportunity that's the worst
case scenario I gotta go or Joe you suck
that dick so good like we're taking with
us they're like damn he did a good job
it was amazing yeah what did they come
back to after they don't they let me go
to like man that [ __ ] was
take you to the movies tonight
[Laughter]
the money in cryptocurrency I do yeah
yeah what I enjoy it I have aetherium I
have this one calling me sago that I
like a lot yeah I follow a lot of
different projects I just got a Bitcoin
I used to do dogecoin - hey dogecoin
secure dude you make fun of those funny
it's fine
yeah well the network is secure - like
you can't they haven't hacked dogecoin
like it's it's I don't want to act know
for sure exactly it's a great mean point
no I can't believe that me miss actually
have holds a value it's great yeah so
cool I'm so cool
nope at Cal so like let's say you're
famous right enough games
yeah he needs armed security for not
only himself but every family member
because they could get kidnapped and
held for ransom because the Philippines
yeah like if you speak with an American
accent over there my grandma was saying
that was he fooled just like they start
like following you like let's kidnap
them it's crazy how it's like they need
all its secure you but for all they know
that could be inside jobs and so just
dude yeah dude [ __ ] exactly that's
true too because a security can't turn
on you if you don't pay them good enough
well oh [ __ ]
anything that's a high level of money
like when I watched that Pablo Escobar
show narcos like I'm like I can't [ __ ]
without much money like that much cash
because there's always gonna be corrupt
people around that much cash yeah more
money more problems
that's why everything needs to be
electronic I like cash like what a mine
it's cool I just like see a lot of money
just stacked up well you should watch
good girls I want to [ __ ] on a huge pile
of money but I made STP you were [ __ ]
a public bank you job thank you it's in
my own home and
yeah yeah
money bit from it what it'll be for
people with no money dude I'd lick money
I'll [ __ ] kiss money you know what I
see basketball players missin trophies
that [ __ ] out Mike that's gross but
kissing money I think it's funny it's
freshly printed yeah I guess so
but you're gonna get paper cuts dude is
that Hey look I'll put a blanket on top
of it or some [ __ ]
you could be bottom on that on that
money ride yeah [ __ ] that it's like
[ __ ] on haystacks you or no joke has
you never done it yeah don't tell me
this [ __ ] I don't know it could be very
soft and cushy that's true
[ __ ] on money might be nice if you
wash it and then blow-dry it and you
make it like that old but that old money
though like that what it's all like
about to tear it's so soft
yeah but how about the smell of money
you want to watch that [ __ ] off you
don't know if you want a soft nur money
do you think new money has the same
smell as like weathered money though
whether money has that smell like a
library book yeah yeah money smells
what's up I want to [ __ ] on the whole
month nobody smells like a like an old
library book yeah yeah to me it smells
like the you know the handlebars from
like the playground the middle
playground lot of fingers huh oh yeah it
does like that smells like pennies and
[ __ ] I can smell some money right now
don't newish that's new but what a facts
dude
oh yeah it's it that smell you guys
wanna see you guys wanna hit puts into
the [ __ ] world
yeah it's not the smell for sure I feel
like get some cash smell it join us
dollars that's no different
I feel really cool
[ __ ] about Pablo Escobar now you're
gonna [ __ ] that's time yeah smells a
little very good but it won't get debris
on there I'm high off the [ __ ] cast
right now here you can keep it keep it
[Music]
[Music]